[inaudible].
Here's the language and heres a brain,
and this is a brain on language.
Just look at this brain in case you're
not up to date on all the sites.
There's a whole lot going on here.
There are neurons and glial cells,
capillaries and myelinated axons.
All this anatomy,
but the sexiest stuff to focus on has
been the nerve cells in your cerebral
cortex.
That's this outside layer here.
The inside looks whitish.
This stuff looks gray.
Hence the terms of white
matter and gray matter.
The first real evidence of the brain's
role in language came not from observing
normal healthy brains using
language but from damaged brains.
This started back in the 18 hundreds
when pioneering researchers dissected the
brains of a phase JAKKS.
The ancient Greek word, uh,
pasea simply means speechlessness
patients suffering from Aphasia have head
injuries that disrupt their abilities
to understand or produce speech.
It turns out that specific linguistic
difficulties were associated with lesions
in specific parts of the cortex.
The logic involved in pinning down these
language centers of the brain is pretty
simple.
If someone doing action a
has a healthy region be,
but someone else who has
damaged to region B can't do a,
then it looks like region B
is necessary for action. A
in 1861 of French surgeon named Bull
Balka began to study the brains of a phase
yaks and hunted down just such a region,
apparently crucial for speech production.
A region we today called Broca's
area inspired by broke his findings,
a German doctor,
an anatomist Carl van Nica,
went and found another such region.
This one linked to linguistic
understanding, as you might've guessed,
that region is called Venegas area.
A little side note for you,
anatomy buffs or anyone
looking for extra credit.
Today's most widely used
system for cutting the brain
into regions was proposed
by another German
anatomist Corbion Broadman.
This outer surface of the brain we've
been admiring has over two dozen of these
Broadman area's brokers,
corresponds to Broadman area's 45 and 44
well 22 his home to Veronica's area in
your brain specifically.
Both of these are most likely
in your left hemisphere
with all of the technological leaps
forward we've made in brain imaging since
broke his day looking inside the brain
to see what's lighting up where has
obviously become even more important,
but don't let the Uffizi acts mislead you.
What we're searching for inside the
brain isn't necessarily straight forward.
The way researchers speak about it,
it's not as if neuroimaging gives us
the exact brain location of language or
have love or any other human concept.
Instead we get to see
the areas of the brain,
the activation of the actual brain cells
that are involved in performing a task.
These days.
There are two fields that tackle our topic
of the day where teachers language on
a burn, and Chris, you've
already forgotten the first one.
Neuro linguistics makes an
entire discipline out of
the kind of research we've
been chatting about
cycle linguistics or related field,
as the name implies is
crazy about language,
but it takes on general questions like
how do humans acquire language and how do
humans speak and understand with a
focus on the role of the mind in these
activities.
The two fields inform each other,
meaning that there's a high degree of
interdisciplinarity here with all this
stuff about the brain
going through your brain.
Think for a minute about two 20th century
models of language in model number
one,
human language is a collection of
behaviors that are conditioned by external
stimuli.
Verbal behavior,
language that gets a favorable response
will be reinforced and repeated.
This is a perspective called behaviorism
and it places the brain in a background
role.
Model number two is a very popular
linguistic model of language known as
nativism.
It holds that language is
an innate mental faculty.
Grammar isn't just a
linguistic concept anymore.
It's actually born into
every healthy human brain,
but instead of marginalizing the brain
by focusing on external behavior and
operant conditioning,
and instead of bringing linguistics to
the brain by mapping grammatical concepts
onto brain areas,
perhaps we could be a little more
considerate of what the brain is actually
doing. When we articulate our
understanding of language. Yes.
Being that specific with our familiar
general academic terms will require a bit
more intellectual muscle than ignoring
the brain or slapping stickers like
language, grammar, speech on
to some part of your cortex,
but consider it an invitation,
an invitation.
Get to know your brain and your
brain on language a bit better.
Thanks for learning with me.